Tight Times is when you're tested hot,
it's an,
it's a moment when you can redefine and
slash or sustain the definition of the
firm that you've had up to now.
So if you already a high commitment,
high performance from a,
you want to make decisions that are
consistent with the path you've been on
a,
so you,
uh,
and,
and if you are not a high commitment,
high performance from,
you want to see this as an opportunity
to redefine the nature of the firm,
the relationship between yourself and
the employees,
the nature of the,
of the culture and so forth.
So how do you do that?
Uh,
uh,
you,
you do not do that by maintaining
distance between yourself and those who,
who,
you know,
you're going to have to hurt all.
So there's gotta be,
there's gotta be some hurt here,
uh,
but some of the policies are,
first of all,
to try to create a,
a,
an equality of sacrifice.
So one of the,
uh,
one of the approaches,
high commitment,
high performance organizations use is to
have a pay freeze or a across the board
pay cut as opposed to slicing and dicing
and maintaining,
you know,
only only certain people and laying off
people you want to maintain as many of
the people as you can that you may still
have to let people go,
but that's a last stage and if you do
need to let them go,
you let them go based on,
uh,
based on the fact that somehow their
position is going to be eliminated.
They,
what they're doing is going to be no
longer central strategically in the
organization.
Uh,
and it's based on some measure of
performance contribution.
But you try to maintain as many of the
employees as you can.
So you take nucor steel,
another high commitment high performance
company which has,
which was born right,
they didn't need to transform.
What they've done is cut across the
board.
I mean the steel industry has been
horrible.
So they have been cutting pay by as much
as 50 percent across the board and
making sure that senior leaders is
equality of sacrifice senior leaders to
taking that 50 percent cut and more,
uh,
that employees understand that,
secondly,
that you're trying to get more
engagement with people around solving
the firm's problems in tight times.
So some of the ideas we talked about
earlier,
bringing people together,
giving them a voice about what it is
that the firm can do better both to
improve productivity and performance and
also make their life better.
So again,
duality of goals.
How do we do things right for people and
how do we do things right for
performance,
but engaging people in honest
conversation.
So here's what we're trying to do.
First of all,
tell us what we're trying to make sense.
Have you,
do you have any suggestions?
Uh,
and then engaging them in what the firm
can do differently and better.
And the argument I would make is that
when,
if you haven't already done that,
what you will learn is an awful lot of
stuff you should have learned five,
10 years ago about how the firm can be
improved and how productivity can be
improved.
But now you're engaging people in a time
of need for them and the firm.
And that will make it easier for you
actually to engage people as opposed to
harder.
But all of this requires that the
leaders engage directly with the people.
It can't be done through announcements,
it can't be done through sending your hr
people out to do it.
Uh,
they can be assisting you,
but,
but you have to go out and talk to
people directly.
Uh,
and so for example,
diaries,
ice cream on the west coast when they
had some tough times,
uh,
quite a few years ago,
the CEO and some of the leadership team
went around to every part of the
organization.
Talk to every employee practically about
what the situation of the company was,
what,
what was wrong,
what will,
what the problem was,
why they were had to make some changes.
And then engage people in discussions
about that.